hello and welcome to this video playing
Johann Hendra here on leeches what is he
going to do Knight f6 is very flexible
you don't know what's going on for a
couple of moves until we get some sort
of decision see five six all very
standard moves no I don't know if I can
take him one of the lines that that's
it's a bit uncommon
well I'd like to get an Evo of course
ideal as 93 e4 and then g4 hmm it's not
that easy together
93 should be seven yeah maybe
and then just deform if one night c6
looks a bit odd for me yeah I just
wonder if that rookie ones then made
much sense probably not it's not a huge
issue yes lost some time with Bishop b5
b7 and so on
so it's not a a really huge issue
yeah it looks like some simplifications
are going to happen probably look here I
need to go to see one probably anyhow I
expected that and probably 25 not 25
okay okay Queenie of three is very
natural anyway on do I have something
better problem playing for the weeks is
six square is a standard bring a
standard strategy a classic games
Botvinnik Donna from the 60s we're bored
winning use that in really instructive
fashion that knight c6 IDM yeah let's
see what he does on night at five you're
going to sacrifice the Queen or what's
the point right f5 Queen d1
nope don't get
Oh to see not immediately get killed now
Quincy's six went to yeah it's going to
be very bad for him but I don't really
see anything better
it's really cool blooded yeah [ __ ]
Casey eight I mean I didn't really see a
gray move either but yeah here night
aged six is just winning on the spot
maybe something else also is good Queen
f6 is flashing but I think this is
actually just better if this does the
same thing Queen f6 s rook c3 and then
yeah minister cesium so let's have a
look
I was a bit surprised by Bishop b5 I
mean 95 is extremely normal II d5 also
looks more standard Bishop takes is just
losing time and you can if I go Knight
c3 you have to go back and then you move
it twice and it's not clear that this
helps I mean if you if you you can view
it like that if I play Knight c3 and he
goes back that's the same as taking with
the night and then voluntarily
retreating which you probably won't do
without if you take here you're not
voluntarily going back to f6 anytime
soon so if you want to take with the
piece stick with the night okay rook e1
maybe not the best move my basic idea
was that I wanted to be ready for you
for but now as I looked at it I saw that
96 is probably not good
white he's got this idea and I cannot
play the phone now doesn't work so I
switched to deform he took it in night X
yeah and here you have to be precise
with black Queen d7 or queen c8 our
engine moves that do make a lot of sense
they they intend to go to b7 quickly for
example Quincy eight I would go here
three I guess and then and then black
and decide if I was interesting and
that's an additional benefit of the
Queen on c8 yeah if you can play five
here and I don't have anything as
specific yeah okay I'm in this efore
93-95 is good hood okay he took with
written with the he played 95 which is
very slow he's three six 194 was a good
movement I would see one is to be as
good as well and it gets difficult now
with simply with the development
disadvantage Queen d5 Queen f3 I would
have played and for example after the
trade group do you hate as the engine
gives you're always going to be a little
bit better for white simply due to the
better mobilization often it you have
this little initiative due to the better
pieces that you win the a pawn something
like that
and here yeah look AC ADIS yeah
basically losing Queenie 8 is better I
mean white must be better
due to the mentioned better piece
placement but it is a lot tougher than
this yeah here Queen c6 was relatively
best as I mentioned
it's not fun mmm I have this I have to
check on aged six I think I probably
would have played Bishop f6 but this is
looking very good Liam this is a really
excellent position the bishop he is so
strong always making sure that there is
no roopd aid coming I think I probably
would have played Bishop f6 that was
what I was thinking taketake yeah and he
takes F he takes them I didn't even see
that okay I mean okay it's better
celibate NIH it's a lot stronger
yeah after Queen here it's just over
Queen f6 or Bishop f6 they both win the
game quite convincingly
okay yes thanks for watching